[Musik]
sein hallo blome erinnert hier an
jemanden ja sie meinen sie ich weiß
nicht an wären sie mich einfach kein
sakko an deshalb ja sie sehen aus wie
stefan aus aber ich bin größer
ich weiß auch nicht ob viele leute egal
corona riskieren wir die zweite welle
dann muss ich sie jetzt mal was fragen
ja also die erste welle meinetwegen war
das was sozusagen womit das alles
angefangen habt obwohl es in deutschland
ehrlich gesagt auch so eine richtige
welle ja gar nicht war denn es gibt
bestimmte gegenden von deutschland da
ist die welle ehrlich gesagt sorry aber
gar nicht angekommen nämlich im osten
zum beispiel aber egal lassen der dass
die zweite welle wann wäre dann
eigentlich die zweite welle weil im
april lockerungen sozusagen besprochen
wurden ende april haben dann manche groß
mögen der experten geschrieben liebe
virologen wenn wir auf den april zurück
kunden werden dann werden wir uns
wünschen auf euch gehört zu haben
dann vergingen hat neurologen die gegen
die lockerungen waren genau dann verging
ich helfe gern vergingen der juden und
es ist ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so
fürchterlich viel passiert deshalb meine
frage wenn jetzt irgendwann im september
oktober november eine zweite welle kommt
ist das dann immer noch die relative
ausgelöst habe durch die lockerung im es
ist nicht im mai es ist nein es ist
nicht so kapitalistische andere die
dritte welle und die zweite haben wir
überspringen es ist nicht so kompliziert
erscheinen wie sie versuchen auf einem
bein darzustellen
die zweite welle ist die die nach der
ersten kommt das nennt man eine
ordnungszahl die erste welle war das
groß oder klein die zweite welle ist die
die kommt wenn sie kommt ich lieben
ihren slogan wir haben immer recht auch
wenn sie nicht recht haben haben sie
anschluss doch recht es ist die frage
doch was definieren sie also wenn das
hat viele spannende frage ist jetzt die
ersten fünf kommen pumpe die frage ist
doch wann müssen wir von einer welle
reden die mine wegen ein ganzes
bundesland oder gar die ganze
bundesrepublik erneut in ein loch down
wie gehabt mitte 20 märz zurück zwingt
das wird noch spannend also wir haben
jetzt einen fall mehrere über 1000
infizierte ganz enge räume dicht
beieinander also diese zahl 50 pro woche
neuinfektionen auf 100000 einwohner weit
überschritten
da war eine fleischfabrik nackter
zugrunde wie man jetzt ziemlich genau
weiß in die tests drumherum haben
bislang zumindest noch keine grosse
verbreitung gezeigt
also ist das jetzt schon eine zweite
welle da würd ich sagen nein deswegen
reicht es zu sagen wir nehmen mal diese
flasche weg aus dem spiel zum einen und
zum zweiten halten wir die ausreise et
cetera beschränkungen auf diese region
beschränkt nicht auf ganz nrw seien auch
diese jungs also daher in so kannst du
trittst oder fährt mit vertretern der
stadt herunter weil ich endlich was
gerade da wieder hochkommen ich weiß ich
sollte diese wie gesagt warum darf ich
darf ich sie was fragen bitte
tschuldigung aber nehmen dass wir nicht
über warum hat man das nicht als das
alles losging in rosenheim auch genauso
wie man halt nein entschuldigung nur ich
viele kleine verlange sowie journalisten
harassen warum hat man das nicht gleich
auch in rosenheim damals hatten sie auch
immer wohler und war das gehirn
infiziert dass sie kommt mit dem gehirn
nicht mehr riechen hatten sie das warum
musste bremen lockdown gehen wenn in
rosenheim corona ausbricht können sie
mir das nochmal sie gesehen haben dass
begonnen hat es ja in bei webasto dessen
hersteller von einem autositz heizungen
glaube ich und dann stellte man fest das
geht aber in bayern massiv warum und das
breitet sich in beiden einander
geschwindigkeit aus den nicht mehr
kontrollierbar ist man konnte nicht mehr
zurück verziehen
woher kommen jetzt diese 50 neue
infektionen oder woher kommen diese 150
neue infektionen das wusste man dann
einfach nicht mehr ergo hatte man die
prognose die ich für damals zumindest
natürlich auch heute noch im rückblick
für plausibel halten für angemessen und
für politisch wenn sie waren achtung
alternativlos halte hat man gesagt wenn
das in dieser geschwindigkeit durch
bayern geht damit legen wir lieber das
ganze bundesgebiet haben mehr können
wäre nicht lahmlegen weil polen und die
angrenzenden anderen können wir aus
berlin zumindest nicht nahm sie haben
sich dann ja auch alle selber lahmgelegt
so aber warum will warum weil sie
dachten das ist gar kein ja ja ja okay
sie wollen die truppen nicht zu rücken
lasst uns nicht zurück kommen egal oder
ich glaube wir müssen da habe ich doch
noch mal wenn jetzt eine zweite welle
kommt reagieren wir dann genauso wie
beim ersten mal machen wir das alles
genauso nochmal oder was haben wir denn
gelernt aus dem ersten mal wurden dann
in deutschland fehler gemacht aus denen
man für das zweite mal lernen wird jetzt
wird ja über die schweden fahren ja alle
dass er so war hier so ganz merken ganz
kurz jetzt bin ich hab sie und jetzt ist
ja ganz lustig die die schweden
praktisch immer erst alles um die machen
das ganz anders das muss ja dann falsch
wenn die das anders machen und dann
seitdem praktisch immer so h da schon
wieder ein schwede gestorben jetzt kann
mal wieder sehen jetzt fallen alle
praktisch für die schweben ja weil der
obere schweden drosten gesagt hat das
ist ja nur fünf da immer so will er bei
schäden ist ja fünfter kleiner da gibt
es eben nur einen und nicht 5 und der
hut der hat drei ecken der heißt ja
genau und der hat jetzt irgendwie gesagt
irgendwie ja wenn ich noch mal könnte
welches alles anders machen ist aber in
deutschland anders wir wussten dass
damals zum genau richtig und machen das
nächstes mal genauso roboter ich glaube
nicht er ist prognose wurden auch fehler
nein das ist dass irgendwann
wahrscheinlich ja glaube ich wird man
bestimmte fragen bestimmte dinge wird
man hinterfragen
die geschichte mit den schulen und ob
die wirklich flächendeckend so lange
geschlossen werden mussten ist glaube
ich und ich muss sagen umstritten
die einen sagen ja hier kinder
infizieren sich uns gegeben ist auch
weiter wenngleich vielleicht weniger als
erwachsene also als andere altersgruppen
und trotzdem so eng aufeinander
das hätte mindestens als lehrer
abgeräumt da hätten sie auch kein
unterricht gehabt also ob das jetzt
schon entschiedene sache ist wie mancher
glaubt verlegt das war aber falsch das
hätte man nicht hat mir seine ganze
kinder menschheits generation umgelegt
worden in sachen bildung das hat es für
grotesk übertrieben da ist eine halbjahr
ausgefallen mein gott mein bruder der
kann auch lesen und schreiben der ist
einmalig oder west durchziehen die
signatur hochbegabt ihre kinder ist der
termin hätte man das machen wir
außerhalb der schule bei ihnen zu hause
sie haben den begriff kurz schuljahr da
wurde mal um den schuljahresbeginn in
den sommer zu kriegen wurde mal
zweieinhalb jahren 1 gepackt jetzt auch
gut gegangen die menschen können auch
noch lesen und sport sowie irgendwas
standards machen wie sie sicher wissen
politiker beantworten sie doch mal meine
frage werden wir irgendetwas anders
machen wenn die 23
meine prognose ist wenn es meine
prognose ist ein lockdown bundesweit so
wie wir ihn hatten mitte ende märz
restaurants zu alles zu schulen ccc den
werden wir vielleicht wieder kriegen
aber die auftragsstände bis man das
wirklich beschließt wird viel höher
liegen also einen tag gewesen auch
letztes mal sie hört zu warten bis sie
hören ist oder war das damals richtig
das so zu machen
ich verstehe es nicht ich glaube dass
bestimmte massnahmen die sie quasi
ergreifen um sich auf die sichere seite
zu bringen und sie vorsicht ist die
mutter der porzellankiste better safe
than sorry ist
das heißt die haben sie einmal ergreifen
können ich glaube nicht dass man ist in
dieser form ein zweites mal greifen kann
weil man auch sieht was es kostet was
man vorher zumindest nur schätzen konnte
jetzt wird das wussten die alle genau
was es kostet wenn man sie haben uns
alles lahm legt wenn man die kinder zu
hause lässt wenn man die alten einsperrt
wenn man die frauen einsperrt so dass
sie ihren männern ausgeliefert sind
hätte ich gesagt wusste man dass die
ganze zeit und sie haben auch alle
aufgeschrieben es ist nur nein es ist
nur sozusagen unter dem virologische
totalitären über argument irgendwie aber
das wichtigste ist der kampf gegen das
virus untergegangen und was ich
interessant finde unschuldig jetzt komme
ich dann auch mal aus der deckung meiner
fragen raus zur aussage setzen ist ja
auch wichtig was ich interessant finde
ist natürlich wurden in deutschland auch
massive fehler gemacht bei der
bekämpfung dieser epidemie und ich hoffe
dass wir am zweiten mal aus diesen
fehlern lernt in dem man eben nicht
wieder in einen lock down geht der
gesellschaft nicht zuzumuten ist der
wirtschaftlich zuzumuten ist und das
bedeutet natürlich unterm strich dass
man weil der impfstoff hat noch nicht da
ist irgendwie wird lernen müssen mit
gewinnen schlossen als realität zu leben
und entschuldigung
entschuldigung ich bin der festen
überzeugung immer noch dass das auch von
vornherein der richtige ansatz gewesen
wäre denn es gab sehr viele leute gesagt
haben freunde das wird aber ganz schön
lange dauern bis er ein impfstoff bei
soja und gesehen zwei jahre so haben
doch gesehen locker und verbringen nein
natürlich nicht aber sie haben doch
gesehen wie die zahl der infektion
mädchen auch die zahl der toten
irgendwie bei allen unwägbarkeiten
korreliert mit den maßnahmen also man
kriegt das epidemiologische geschehen
die ansteckung runtergedrückt wenn man
diese bewegungs beschränkungen kontakt
beschränkungen
er lässt und durch edle umlagen dass die
masken zum beispiel wahnsinnig viel
positives wir hängen ja kann schon sein
aber ich glaube wenn ein kleines gerne
die kaum merkbare eingriffe in unser
aller lena ich würde sagen masken ja tag
macht ja kann schon sein ich glaube dass
gar nicht sich treffen mit oder ohne
maske auch ein bisschen geholfen hat es
liegt in der logik der dinge wissen sie
dann kann ich ihnen noch nicht durch die
maske was zu pusten wenn wir uns gar
nicht sehen aber noch einmal ich glaube
auch dass in der abwägung wird es anders
laufen das heißt aber nur der punkt an
dem wirklich zu einem noch dran
gegriffen werden würde
liegt höher wenn sie so wollen da muss
mehr passieren bis es dann zu einem
lokal am herrentag hat ich glaube weil
es gesellschaftlich nicht durchzusetzen
ist nochmal so umfassend einzugreifen
wenn ich wirklich die hütte brennt und
jetzt stelle ich ihnen eine frage würden
sie denn sagen locker machen wir nie
wieder ganz egal was passiert
das ist das ist reine polemik war das
genauso wie lange er stand damals und
fuge brutaler unfug ich bin der meinung
dass das was da jetzt in nordrhein
westfalen gemacht wird das sind ja
lokale lockt als vollkommen richtig ist
übrigens ein besonders widerliches
beispiel für dysfunktionalen
kapitalismus und für versagen der
politik denn die miesen zustände in
diesen echt schwein und verrichtungen
die kannte man ja vorher
und wenn die deutsche
landwirtschaftsministerin sagt fleisch
für 150 das kino das darf nicht sein da
muss man sagen erzählt doch mal der
landwirtschaftsministerin tour halt was
dagegen meine politik versagen hoch zehn
egal das ist aber es ist jetzt nicht und
sich der kreis zu bashen ändern sie was
in den regeln und dann bewegt sich das
ist meiner meinung nicht weiß ist
politik politik versagen ist das
versagen absolut und hätte ist zumal sie
wissen können so aber jetzt wäre ja und
ich bin sogar der meinung dass eben doch
das reicht in lokaler locker ist
vollkommen in ordnung wenn es sein dass
ein bundesweiter warum muss bremen in
den walk down geben wenn in rosenheim
die hütte brennt das verstehe ich nicht
aber sie merken doch dass es miteinander
zusammenleben schon mal gesagt habe ich
es einfach noch mal ein sieg sie merken
dass wir das mittel zusammen jetzt
werden die menschen aus gütersloh
stigmatisiert also wer jetzt gt ich
glaube das ist gütersloh ok menschen in
gütersloh wenn sowieso stückmann sie
sich jetzt wahrscheinlich
ich finde das wort übrigens die einfach
der bertelsmann die die können die sind
per die können nicht die quartiere also
wie auch immer die menschen aus
gütersloh wir können jetzt nicht mehr in
norden fahren weil der neue oder nicht
mehr in die küste zum urlaub fahren weil
die küstenregion angst haben also das
heißt auch dass wir uns erneut in
anführungsstrichen eingestellt aber vor
allem an alle grenzen zu jetzt sind nur
die grenzen von gütersloh zu das ist
halt so ja aber sie sehen doch das ist
ihnen dort also der nächste schritt
wende sich das eben nicht eindämmen
lässt und das virus macht eben doch nur
begrenzt an
bezirks gemarkungen halt dann werden sie
natürlich diesen doktoren ausweiten
müssen am ende sind sie möglicherweise
wieder war im bundesweiten doch das ist
überhaupt nicht ausschließen und das
sollten sie auch nicht
ausschließen weil noch geht es ja um
menschenleben das interesse ist da steht
ist doch dass das sozusagen verknüpft
mit einer gleichheits debatte das gesagt
hat das virus macht alle gleich was
gelogen ist weil das virus macht halt
die eher verstärkt ungleichheiten und
macht die leute nicht live und obwohl
man natürlich muss man ungleiches auch
ungleich behandelt so zu sagen dass da
endlich als quasi linker sage wenn hier
gegen diese die idee der großen
gleichmacherei wenn wir in gütersloh ein
problem haben kümmern wir uns um
gütersloh dann kümmern wir uns nicht um
güstrow oder aber wenn sie feststellen
dass sie das problem in gütersloh wo es
im moment noch ist weil es eben ganz
klar aus dieser flasche bekommt wenn sie
merken dass ist da nicht halten können
weil es eben nichts ist was sie mit dem
auto oder federstrich eindämmen können
und sagen kannst da was kommt aber hier
nicht weiter weil ich hier ist die
gemarkungsgrenzen dass warendorf hier
ist gütersloh und du jetzt mal den
schnabel kleines virus wenn sie das
merken dann sind sie natürlich in der
debatte was what's next was kommt als
nächster schritt und das sollte sich die
bundesregierung beziehungsweise
landesregierung das nächste ganz gut
überlegen denn das schwieriger wird es
sein den zweiten lok tor den zweiten
maßnahmen ob es bist du ein wort ankommt
oder nicht den leuten zu erklären auf
die ist ja ankommt beim ersten mal haben
die alle mitgemacht als yahoo.com panik
waren als sie die bilder seien die
seiten mal wird es viel viel schwerer
dann reden sie doch jetzt gehen sie doch
mal jetzt raus ins freie und wir uns
stellen sie sich die ethischen
abwägungen werden anders getroffen wird
unterm strich dann in kauf nehmen dass
mehr leute sterben denn das bedeutet
dass er immer in wahrheit am ende des
tages ist es eigentlich nur wie viel
tote aus der risikogruppe ist man bereit
in kauf zu nehmen das klingt genauso
bitter wie es ist das ist halt so und
das ist sozusagen da haben die schweden
eine andere entscheidung getroffen und
ich würde jetzt mit ihnen sind jetzt
unterhalb der total jetzt mal witz hatte
echt und man hört so lustig ist es den
wald auch alles gar nicht und man wird
zwangsläufig wenn eine zweite welle
kommt in deutschland das anders bewerten
das ja das eigenartige daran und genauso
wie die schäden gesagt haben oder haben
wir was falsch gemacht werden früher
eingreifen müssen werden die deutschen
sagen wo wir haben zu früh angegriffen
ein nächstes mal machen wir das später
das merkwürdige ist es wird sich
sozusagen alles im laufe der zeit
irgendwie aneinander angleichen das ist
nämlich das interessante die extreme
sozusagen werden sich an leichen in
seinen spaß haben kann es geht es ihm
ein
sie meinen sind daher ihren ding auf
drogen sind auch nur menschen und
politiker nahmen politiker womöglich man
taucht sie war manager albanern ernstes
thema nein
[Musik]